Okay, so tickets
are 50 each.
Obviously, we
need an eighth.
Ok.
Plus drinks, that's like
200 bucks total.
And since Todd wouldn't
give me my paycheck.
Girl!
You took all of
his office supplies.
Listen, what I do
at my place of work
is none of your godamn
business, okay?
Okay, I think you really
need to be fired really soon.
I know.
("What a Wonderful World"
playing)
Oh, I love this song.
Ugh--
This is a slave song.
It's not
a slave song.
Yes, it is.
It's widely known
by the black community
that "What a Wonderful World"
is, like, a slave song.
Right, right, right, I
totally forgot that you're,
like, the voice of the whole
black community.
It's a thing--
Google it.
It's in
a Fugees song.
Wyclef's like, "And I think
to myself."
He's like
angry about it.
I feel like all we ever talk
about is black people
and slaver...y...
Hi.
I would like to
return these items.
I once owned them
personally,
but I have no
use for them now, so.
Your total comes
to $135.67.
Yes!
Shit-- Yes!
Oh.
You know, we'd love
to get that in liquid cash.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, what about
my fishbowl of change?
There's got to be, like, 30
or 40 bucks in there?
Can you leave?
Yeah, we're gonna--
We're ending
the convo.